yeah but like it's weird because I think
a lot of people thought that the last
job that would be taken over is kind of
like the creative job right we all
thought we we all thought that that you
know that'd be a point where computers
can get smart to do a lot of like the
specialist jobs that we have to study
for and stuff like that but creative
jobs art music that can never be
replicated and it's it's weird seeing
the kind of like the AI art kind of like
well we're going are we going down that
rabbit hole like controversy yeah it
happened within the last few months if
anything I mean a lot of things are
automated now physically but obviously I
mean think about it like still you have
to build a [__] robot yeah you have
to build something and test it but when
you can just run code over and over
again and keep tweaking it and keep
running it on these super computers it
doesn't require you to build anything
it's like okay well yeah it makes way
more sense that this stuff could be
replicated and something especially like
music is anyone really surprised that AI
was able to replicate music like when
you think about it it's it's not that
complicated it's well
this is coming from the guy who doesn't
make music by the way from the beeps and
boops to me to me it's not that
complicated oh my gosh now I know now I
know how the like artists feel when the
AI odd came out I'm yeah I'm offended
what am I saying okay listen listen that
is okay that is a general sweeping
segment am I saying that AI music is
sounds indistructible No No but can it
make something that sounds pretty much
like normal music or very passable music
yeah of course that'd be like a [__]
Symphony that sounds amazing no of
course yeah you might I don't know and
like you know what I mean like is anyone
really surprised that given the tools
that we had to make music digitally
anyway that right would be able to
figure out oh hey if we just feed it a
[__] ton of information this is what
music looks like to a robot this is what
it sounds like hey give it a shot of
course it's gonna be like this yeah but
that's the thing right and I feel that's
like a a can of worms that like oh lot
of people try and you know Skip around
the conversation with of like that you
know because like when that whole uh AI
art like uh programming came out you
know and it's been coming out for a
while but like about a month or so ago
like you know there was that one air
program that like everyone on Twitter
was using because it was like oh this is
really [__] cool to pay money for his
role to [__] scam right but it's like
you know I you know I I did it because I
I did it for a video because I thought
you know oh what kind of [__] up
Creations can this AI make of me right
and you know it was funny and you know
for entertaining purposes but then
obviously I got a lot of like backlash
from like you know the art community of
being like oh so you're not gonna
commission real artists but then you're
going to get art from a IR that steals
other artists work and I'm just like I
hate that argument because it's like
other like human artists steal from
other human artists as well
and it's a tough conversation to have
right because it's that's a fact that
people don't want to admit no I I it's
it's it's it's it's a tough conversation
it's a tough we're going into like
Uncharted terrorists
like a AI has literally it's it's a tool
so powerful that we've had to think
rethink what is morally right right so
you know the AI training itself you know
that's building a tool that can train
itself that's that's incredible right
the fact that there's an AI can train
yourself two emulate a lot of human art
and art made by real people to the point
where a lot of it can almost seem
indistinguishable to a normal person
that doesn't understand art of course
now morally being able to train that AI
using artwork pre-existing artwork which
people have
have uh you know spent years and years
perfecting and honing their skills
um only to be added to a database to
help train this AI in order to
basically make a lot of their work
obsolete is that morally correct you
know that's that's that's something
that's we've not really had to think
about yeah because I don't know what
kind of
press I don't know when in history we've
had I'm sure there is something similar
in history that's not going through my
head right now but it's it's a
complicated question yeah where we've
just it's it's something we've morally
not had to think about but we've now we
we now have to think about it just
because this one tool is so powerful
yeah you know and I feel it's a
difficult conversation to have as well
because it's like it's very much morally
speaking in my opinion it's very much in
a gray zone right it's like you know
there are there are benefits to this
kind of Technology you know expanding
and stuff like that in the art wall but
as well like you don't have to be an
artist to know that there are also some
demerits to it right what a out of
curiosity what benefits do you think
there is from having a IRS as opposed to
so a lot of so a lot of the kind of
backlash I guess opinions that I saw
about the whole air program coming out
from like actual artists yeah is that in
the in the odd world it's it's very much
like a lopsided kind of uh argument men
of like a lot of people look at it and
go this is a program that is stealing
you know other people's art and you know
like passing it off as like you know art
but okay there are also a lot of artists
who look at programs like this and go
well okay but at this point in time it
there is still very much a a limit like
a machine limit of just how it can be
when it when it comes to creativity
right now though so right now let the
problem is that you're kind of
essentially yeah a lot of people are
like yeah it's not good enough now but
it's like okay you're You're Building
you know you're assembling the rope to
hang yourself with yeah in a sense right
because yeah and even to begin with it's
not even like they're they're being paid
they're being compensated for artwork
being used it's that I think the main
issue is that people just haven't
consented their artwork being used to
essentially yes okay and I'm and I'm
against that personally as well of
course yeah
the audience got pissed off because by
buying it or using it even though you're
not using it for maybe nefarious
purposes yes by using their services
you're sort of kind of condoning it what
yeah and then I think that's the problem
it's probably because like it's it's
there's been such a shift within this
just these past few months right because
at the beginning of this at the
beginning I was gonna say beginning of
this year at the beginning of last year
yeah hey I was just like haha look at
all these funny things that computers
and AIS can do oh look I search my name
and it does this and now it's getting to
the point where oh this is this can
possibly take people's like livelihoods
and jobs and now now we have to think
what is morally acceptable in terms of
how this AI has been made and how this
tool has come about okay it's like I'll
pose you a question okay so let's let's
say there's an AI that has been trained
to make YouTube videos to make anime Man
videos or something like that and it
gets to a point where your videos have
been user trained or like your videos
have been used to trading I was gonna
say to make videos about anime but you
know you know
it's been trained to make videos about
Japan yes in the style of your style
yeah but it can pump it out way more
faster and way more consistently than
you could ever and if it looks and it
feels like a jury video then it's a big
problem right because yeah they've
essentially used you to replace you and
then you don't get a car so I think I
think the problem is that the laws right
now and the way that it all works is
that this was never ever accounted for
yes you know that someone could just use
your stuff and use it as training
information because normally if you
wanted to say uh learn how to play piano
like Mozart and let's say there's video
footage of it for some reason obviously
there isn't but you could just watch it
and it'll be up to you to try and figure
out how to do it yourself and no one
would bet an eye out there yes yeah but
so if you give that to a machine and the
Machine can just replicate it one for
one and spit it out it's like okay well
hold on
I didn't agree to that yeah when I
publish this video I want people to
watch it I didn't want people to [__]
just replace me with it but but I think
at the same time it's it's going to like
say looking at it from the musical
standpoint right like as someone who has
been writing music my whole life it's
like I find that as like uh you know
maybe not the best way but it is a way
to kind of push the medium further in
terms of its in terms of its current
limits right it's like okay Carly AI has
gotten to the point where it has gotten
pretty close or even similar to what
humans are capable of doing right yeah
but at the end of the day the AI at
least as of right now right there is
still very much a limit that human
creativity
tends to pass yeah so right so I think
in the sense of advancing the art medium
forward
you can look at it in a positive in that
way but at the same time as someone who
has seen AI being made oh sorry or music
being made by AI yeah it is also kinda
terrifying but at the same time at the
end of the day with any kind of like art
and stuff like that humans I think are
just naturally more attracted to
something that is made by a human even
if it might be indistinguishable of
course of course I would like to think
that yeah people like to think they're
smarter than they are and that they
would never fall for stuff like that but
yeah we do right like it's just yes I
mean it depends on the person obviously
yeah part of the real like like I said
we never thought AI would like create a
field to be one of the fields that AI
would take over first but yeah uh like
it I think it's just going it's just
kind of blowing up the fact that you
know even if you think human creativity
is beautiful and amazing which you know
I think it is it's still art is still
defined and based on rules yes and
structure you know we talk about you
know we clown on corner for for like how
music is easy replicatable he like at
the same way
the fact that you can study music means
there is a baseline structure
um that can be learned and obviously can
be replicated and part of the beauty
sometimes comes from breaking that
structure and going going your own
Direction going against the convention
but at the same time that is also based
on the previously defined structure you
know so it's it's kind of
uh it's it it kind of is like taking all
of the gloss off and being like okay
this is what this is this this is what
your creativity actually is this is this
is all of the things but I think that's
why this conversation that's why I feel
though this conversation is so
fascinating right because it makes us
kind of question okay
what is art to begin with now like you
know it it does it's like it makes you
kind of rethink like okay what makes
this one thing artistic and this other
thing not as artistic right I think with
this specific uh controversy that
happened where a lot of people got
really upset about their Arts because
you know I think typically online anyway
well like in the online climate right
now artists who are normally undervalued
anyway yes and don't get paid maybe as
much as they should so it was kind of
like the the cigarette butt being put
out on you when you're already down
right yeah okay so I'm already
struggling to get a fair price for my
art and now I have to compete with this
[__] that's trained off of my [__] like
yeah what the [__] like for example
right uh another AI situation um
remember like I got even like 10 years
ago that Eve bot that one where you
could talk to it oh yeah it would like
flirt back to you no there were a lot of
yeah it's like the AI chatbots oh how
you doing today I'm fine and then you'll
be like oh you're so beautiful and it
was just it was like it was like a dumb
little thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was kind of [__] but you're like okay
well you know you think in the time it
was like slightly upgraded clippy
basically of course you're like this is
cool I'd love to help improve this yeah
I think the we as humans are so curious
and so fascinated by stuff that we're
like this is awesome like nobody nobody
at that time questioned yeah whether we
should get this AI better or not
everyone's like [__] yeah this is cool
yeah this is awesome this is a little
fun thing I do online with my friends
and we all laugh about it yeah and then
you think oh wait what if it gets good
enough where it can just actually scam
people online where I could just it
could DM you on Instagram yeah and it
can sound human and it can ask for your
credit card or some pointers like what
if it could have an extended
conversation with you for weeks and then
you could be scammed out of something
and it's like okay now it's like if it
gets too good because we become
normalized I mean I'd argue that's it's
already happening I don't know if that
happens but like I mean it could happen
it could yeah the point being is that
like I think it it's concerning when
it's already too late yeah it's already
gotten to the point where it's too good
then you're like oh oh we [__] up
yeah
like five ten years ago we thought
that's cute that's nowhere near as good
as the stuff we're making yeah and this
was the the sentiment we had and
obviously now that it's catching up
everyone's kind of scared because
they're like where does this go yeah
where is it going to be in 10 more years
yeah I I think it was just like basic
human naivety to be like to be like oh
this thing exists oh that's that's cute
that's not a problem I'm gonna have to
worry about in my lifetime let's just
watch Sci-Fi movies about it isn't that
so funny right now and now we are in
that sci-fi so yeah there was this
[__] that was just a I don't know who
is Adobe or something there's one
presentation like I don't know like two
three four years ago where it's
basically like off of X amount of
samples of your voice they could pretty
much perfectly replicate yourself yeah
yeah yeah yeah and that was terrifying
too because like now it's like all right
well deep fakes at least those are still
uh yeah they're not great still like
yeah yeah I mean you can do some really
convincing ones but to have your voice
taken feels really weird yeah imagine
that I mean yeah you know yours is on
there on one shrimp shitty one doesn't
sound yeah I mean it doesn't get that
but it can get that yeah and yeah it
just raises a lot of like new morality
questions that you realize oh we are
definitely we are definitely not
prepared for the wrong apocalypse is
coming so they're able to make a deep
fake so they can make a facial uh
reconstruction if you can't they could
take your voice and then now they have
your video ideas
right oh this is obviously a new place
to ask and this is dude [__] cares about
YouTubers get [__] copied yeah
um but it's just you know yeah I think
it's no surprise that the creative
aspects are the first to be uh kind of a
mimicked or uh yeah absolutely because
it's also the average everyday person
doesn't care to interact with a robot
that could maybe fix a phone yeah yeah
right maybe it's cool for someone else
but I'm gonna be like I'll go in the art
I I'll give it I'll talk to the funny
robot yeah why not why are we talking to
robots
why why are we humoring them
this is where the robot would be like
you're a peasant colleague
at the robots feels more real than
talking to humans okay yeah that we
would go online and we would just
[__] chat to a wall right like I saw
the other day
um someone had made
um an AI YouTuber I saw that and I was
just like it's literally just like the
whole Tay thing but just with a voice
thing that was there was a clip that was
going around where they they pleased to
me by name huh they mentioned me by now
really and I had this clip like sent to
me everywhere and it's like this aib
tuber mentioned you by name and I was
like how the [__] that's Joey messenger
yeah it said Joey the anime man and I
was like who who are you how do you know
me but like it's just just seeing it
that that also [__] okay so everyone
right now is at the same stage where
it's just like haha wow how cute an aiv
tube isn't this such a nice cute little
idea but I I swear to God in like five
ten years maybe even soon yeah as soon
as AIS can get to a point where they
have an endearing personality it's
[__] over man
Japan will be definitely the first
country we are we are literally we are
literally in the epicenter of humanity
getting wiped out by YouTubers manager
think about Japan with 100 accepted
YouTuber AI Overlord you know why
because you can't get a [__]
boyfriend
I am waiting for the niji Sanji like aiv
super division to come out I just feel
like I'm sorry but Idol that will never
have a boyfriend never have any
controversy you know hopefully he won't
say anything racist I say hopefully
because God knows what the AI is going
to be trained on you know
here's the thing how do you cancel an AI
an AI is uncountable right because it
can only be trained by humans so who are
the real evil not the P or AI it's the
[__] humans that trained it man I
can't believe you hurt my feelings
my real feelings
oh my God that is very poggers yeah
bottom line everyone in the creative
field is [__] it's on 24 7. well the
bottom line everything every every
artist musician's a [__] YouTubers are
[__] everyone's [__] if you work in
uh you know some engineering or some
stuff you're pretty good when you're
using your hands yeah
I thought programmers were safe but now
there's AI that can do programming maybe
maybe we go maybe we've got to go back
to the Stone Age maybe the only jobs
that will be left is like manual labor
you know tedious manual labor you know I
can't dig
we'll just be building huts and filming
that and be like ha [__] you AI yeah
let's see you're trying to build this
primitive technology YouTubers are just
like my time has gone oh except they've
they've surpassed us when they can beat
us at speedrunning video games that's
when I like said what do you mean when
when an AI can just speed run a video
game on its own and do like the
cheetoskip and all that in the video
game you can already like do it but all
you have to do is feed it a task well
yeah we have to feed it a task right
that's like a video basically playing
though
um yeah we can figure it out all on its
own that's when I'll be impressed when
yeah when an AI can figure out a brand
new like skip then that's when I'm
impressed
videos are gonna be a lot less out of
everything that's like ai's could do I
think that might be one of the easier
things bro you got an AI That's running
a video game 24 7. have you ever watched
those machine learning compilations of
video games after like [__] uh two to
four weeks they're still dumb as [__]
really right now yeah right now right
now yeah you have to put a lot you the
AI on its own cannot learn like you need
to feed it like you need to right like
hey you know like if you watch videos of
it like uh racing a car in a video game
like you have to feed it a lot to get it
even remotely good
um yeah but it depends how how quickly
you can iterate upon itself
um because there's more computing power
the more it can help I guess yeah the uh
I don't know I'm not an expert in this
[__] all I know is that they are bad
Joey you should be ashamed of yourself
wow I can't believe me and about a
million other people uh joining you know
it's like this is the problem is a lot
of other people don't have comment
sections yeah yeah but also but also a
lot of people don't read their
conversations that's true you know what
I'm gonna AI I'm gonna create an AI bot
that gives me wholesome comments
that finds out exactly what porn I'm
gonna jack off to that day I'm tired of
scrolling quite frankly and I will
welcome that one it's like oh BBW today
I wasn't really gonna go for that one
but maybe I think that's just the I'm
feeling lucky button on Google
I'm watching and then decide exactly
what I'm into and when I'm gonna be into
it and the exact time of day because I I
can't trust myself maybe I'm just doing
it for the sake it pings you on your
phone to be like J.O time it vibrates
like really aggressively in your pocket
yeah to turn you on it's like jail time
here's the link off you go yeah it is
already playing on your Chromecast
please enter the bedroom yeah I mean I
mean Jarvis play BBW Paul
as you get wheeled in yeah I mean
we're all just gonna end up like Wally
dude
we're all just gonna end up that's the
one thing that is [__] up about Wally
yeah if you tell me there's a feeding
tube but not something that sucking my
dear
you telling me how to do that manually
[__] that yeah
plot hole in it how are they jerking off
it doesn't look like it's possible it
would have happened if while he was
how do you make sure they don't get as a
getting the resistance in the [__] you
make sure that jacking